hey ram rambling rabbit rabbit can i
speak to you in vc4 for a second
sure
[Music]
yo rambu we could
buy we could buy this hotel we put our
diamonds together we buy this place
i don't know you think i kind of like i
don't i i mean okay it's a it's a good
building right it's big and
oh yeah no but what we do is we buy it
and then we rent it out to jack
we we buy our competition we
buy it and then rent it out to jack yeah
so we just we have the deeds but jack is
there
um i don't know i don't know if that's
legal if i'm entirely honest it's
minecraft
anything goes like okay
no no what we could do is no no what we
could do no oh my god we could buy it
and get jack to turn into a casino
[Music]
i don't know i don't know i mean doesn't
doesn't technically
[Music]
technically uh isn't it technically
tommy's
always in college said that it was i
mean
you said it yourself about logics not
flawed
yeah but like it i don't think he has
the ability to like
sell it should we ask him about it we
should we should go don't be like jack
battlefield
how do two stacks of diamond blocks
sound i'm not going to give them two
stacks of diamonds
i'm not going to give them my you're not
going to use my money why
all i need is a small loan i
mean i'm not gonna give him all i hate
is this no no no
no no no okay the thing is though right
yeah the thing is though
if we if we were to own it right yeah
it's kind of it's kind of a it's kind of
a jerk move because we're renting we're
stealing it from a guy that like doesn't
even
he doesn't even know that like jack has
it oh yeah trey yeah
yeah yeah and then also we need we need
we need friendly competition i mean oh
we
so we want to we want to kill him with
yeah let's go and kill him with kindness
let's go
hey jack manifold we're here to kill you
with kindness
no don't jack manifold it's not it's not
gonna happen
oh wait what did you mean what did you
mean wait what do you mean no i meant i
meant
i mean we just kind of just like let let
things happen here i mean
when you when you think about it when
you think about it like there's already
fighting between like the two people
that work there oh
there's only one person that works here
because the other one is in jail jack
manifold how much is this place
for sale no we're not selling it because
it's my big hotel
okay yeah yeah see he wasn't i knew he
wasn't gonna sell you a room for five
diamonds though
jack your room there's not even a pool
there's no games room there's no kitchen
where's yours
it's on the roof show me your pool we we
have construction
constructing it we're still under
construction yeah no
i wouldn't stay there because it's not
even built mine is built
jackman i mean yours is built and no
one's staying there yeah
so what does that say about boy hello
okay skeppy and bad boy hello who
actually happened to have a mansion
there and also live 10 000 blocks away
yeah but they stay here they have rooms
that's why it says it on the doors
uh i think you've just been played i
don't know could you be in just
they paid for it tobo it doesn't matter
they pay okay if they didn't pay
wait oh wait okay how much is a room
five diamonds how long do i get the room
for
just forever a week
a week yeah you get it for a week i'll
have five rooms
trust me trust me i'm killing him with
kindness five rooms please
okay sure which which rooms do you want
one of them
there's more than five wait there's more
than five rooms you have to show me
specifically spend 25 diamonds for that
i want i want i want the top ones
okay let's come to the top top
we'll get you you'll get don't worry
rambo it's an investment
we can use it you are not responsible
with here we can stake we can do a
stakeout
we can do a stakeout we're doing a
stakeout we're doing a stakeout
[Music]
you're just so oh wait i forgot about
room 10. do you want room 10 this one
will cost you 15 diamonds though 15
diamonds for room 10
what's in room temperature the same as
room nine
and room 11 yeah wait wait there's oh
right okay well never mind these three
will cost you 15 each
uh no you've been up this high yet yeah
you're not you're not a very good
employee
wait you haven't even been up this high
in your own hotel i won
i won i won eight seven i won
eight seven six and five it's in the
name i didn't realize it was this big
which ones do you want i want eight
seven six five and four
all right fine uh all right let me let
me so you rename them all tubber room
one
turbo room two tupperware room three
tableau
which way are we counting sir downwards
so you want to start with one here
[Music]
see this is what we do rambo we support
locusts we support local business this
is our this is good publicity i
appreciate that gentlemen
that's true you know you know this
business is not clearly
yeah it is it definitely is yeah what do
you mean it's struggling we just
sold five rooms yeah we have to support
local business yeah we have to support
someone sold
five rooms to this dude i'm not
struggling at all this is that's
as most of our rooms are now sold you
only have given me four i need one more
yeah i know but i've only had this place
for two days i've just sold five rooms
that's good
i'm not struggling at all but thank you
for your your money you know i think
you've actually sold seven yeah you've
actually sold
yeah well actually those were already
sold those already sold and i i didn't
do that i won't take credit where credit
we've got to support this small business
rambu
this business is not small it's so big
like the name implies
what is this
jack manifolds specifically so soite
this is my suite this is where i live
this is my my bed how much for this
there might be a little there might be a
little bit of one because it's where i
live
how much for this one okay you can't buy
my one
jack how much for this one that's my
wife you
this isn't even furnished you know what
a hundred diamonds if you want to live
in my suite
please jack i want a refund please i
don't want my five rooms anymore
no you don't get refunds we don't do
those well i guess i'll just have to
take him back
no don't kill oh boy
no check manifold
no jack mata phone refunds the policy
says strictly no refunds
i love it when the hotel manager runs
away well i guess
i guess we open the entire hotel now
he's gone around here
i'm gonna come back i guess we start
redecorating
no you don't own it we take down the
wall between the kitchen and the river
just not now i think we're open for a
more open concept i think we take down
the wall between the creatures
living room make it very much a closed
concept i like it the way it is
yeah for a more open concept i say we
take down the wall between this room and
this room
no no more okay no let's take down the
outside walls
let's take down the outside rules yeah
see rambu this is my fan all along now
we own this place
no stop it don't tell me to stop it
stop it
cute right cute what do you mean ha
cute i'd say we need to rebrand this
hotel i think we need a rebrand so we
can enjoy it
there we go i've rebranded it
it's mine you can't steal i will take
you to court tommo
jack i am the lawyer
you will not stand a chance tomorrow i
will sue you
for everything you own you're gonna ask
me to sue myself that's not gonna work
i'm also the judge did i mention i'm
also the judge
tomorrow i'm going to sue you jack i'm
above the law tomorrow i'll win if i sue
you you know what
i'm fighting we're doing this we're
going to court we're going to court
we're going to court this is a custody
battle rambo and it's going to be
aggressive
though oh well that that seems to be a
problem for you to solve
right now represent yourself
jack the court date's in two minutes
because i have to go and play chess soon
we can't do a we tubbo we can't do court
in two minutes i need
we can
yeah i know i've got a date tomorrow but
you know jackie's going on a date
tomorrow
uh on the dream smp in my restaurant i
built
yeah yeah they're going on i have a
restaurant no one goes there but me on
my date
ah i don't know is this serious just
just not
where would you would you go on a date
rambu why would you go on a date ooh
i think like we should go into my
identity marks are really fun
amusement park oh that's true i actually
am terrified of roller coasters
exactly and that's what would make it
fun you are you're an evil evil man you
are
exactly so are we are we still going to
court
i'm going to court i'm going to testify
to myself against jack manifold and win
without him even showing up okay
this is how i do things where i come
from down in the law business
yeah oh my god
yeah yeah oh man you know i was
i was in court on like the like the
third day of me being here
[Music]
jesus
[Applause]
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
magic time
[Music]
we're in the game
oh
[Music]
welcome everyone to pogchamps 3
presented by grip six i'm alexandra and
i'm joined by
honorary woman grand master and previous
pog champs participants
cutie cinderella cutie what does it feel
like being on the other side
good they couldn't get anyone to show up
again so here i am guys
it's me no it's good to have you i saw
your commentary with
robert and that seemed super
entertaining so i feel like
chad is going to be very pumped that
you're here i think they like me i think
i dumb it down enough
you know there's a lot of smart people
in chat but there's a lot of dumb people
in chat
you know you know how to talk to the
people and that's the skill we're here
for
that's what i'm here to reflect and i'm
happy to see you still have hair
cutie i have four days until i have to
go bald i feel like i'm gonna throw up
my anxiety is through the roof
and i'm so excited to have a distraction
for a little bit i'm sorry yeah yeah
yeah
yeah no it's gonna be great it's gonna
be great well speaking of distractions
let's talk a little bit about the format
today
it's going to be single elimination
double round robin
which means that for the match today we
are going to have code miko and tubo
playing two games one is white one is
black
if it is a tie then they are going to go
into the tie breaks which is five
minutes
zero second increment and they are
already in the consolation brackets so
whoever wins is gonna make it
to the semifinals and the loser
unfortunately is gonna be eliminated
cutie last time you were here how far
did you make it
uh i made it i think i only made it to
the first round of the consolation
bracket
well well hey that's as far as one of
the participants today is going to make
it so you're
very much in their same shoes any advice
you would have offered them
i uh i just you know just
i think i see myself a lot in mikko uh
miko and i are really good friends but
number one she
was like [__] this um and then she was
like wait i actually care and she's been
putting a ton of hours in since then
so i'm hoping i'm hoping that i hope she
at least gets a match
yeah there you go the game out of the
match i do think tubble will win but i
hope
i hope miko gets a game i definitely
echo that she is the underdog but it's
good to know that she's been grinding
off stream so
she's had some really strong starts and
she
actually definitely has the potential to
get at least one but let's remind
everybody part of the good pogchamps is
doing as well the community
outreach so chess.com is matching up to
a hundred thousand dollars
of the viewers donations and these
donations will be given to the
participants
preferred non-profit organizations you
can see that depending on how people
place
in the championship bracket or the
consolation bracket it's going to
dictate how much
they can donate so this is pretty cool
cutie do you have any favorite charities
from the participants or maybe any you
like
um well i'm excited for ludwig to get
first place
and donate to no kid hungry uh big fan
of that
so you know we know we're the bias at
all no
bias zero bias i just love no kid hungry
and i just
think they should get all the winning
money so
well cutie you're not the only one
cheering for for ludwig world champion
magnus
carlson also tweeted that he hopes
ludwig wins so
you know at least you're in good company
with who you're rooting for yeah me and
magnus have been having watch parties
um i bring the snacks he brings the
brains and
it's been a good time yeah when is he
coming on eagle rejects i feel like he'd
be a great guest
we will have him soon maybe maybe uh i
guess he is more fit for igor rejects
and housewives of twitch so
we'll see what we can do imagine casey
and minx learning
chess from magnus someone has to make
that happen
that would be the end of him he would be
done
well let's take a look at the match
today so as cutie mentioned
she is good friends with code miko code
miko has been training
tubo has also been training a lot of
chess and he actually originally said
that he was motivated to play chess
to beat his grandpa so
and he's beaten his grandpa two days in
a row now so
regardless what happens i feel like
tubble already wanted
his heart that's so cute
what a sweet boy it is it is actually
very wholesome so
we're going to give him a shout out for
that and we
also want to give a shout out to
guayaqui
for helping make pog champs possible as
guayaqui celebrates 25 years of
regenerative
yerba mate they're sharing cases to
celebrate span the guayaqui emote in
chat for your chance to win and we will
be back
with the match in just a moment the
regeneration of the planet
is integrated into our business model
purchases of guayaqui
yerba mate support stewardship of the
south american atlantic rainforest
and the self-sufficiency of indigenous
communities
these purchases advance a
carbon-balanced renewable energy economy
and provide meaningful employment for
the formerly incarcerated
sales also fuel communities and
activists
driving the regenerative movement
meanwhile
your enjoyment of yerba mate reconnects
you with the vitality of life
when we come to life we care about one
another and stand together to create a
better future
spamming me to kill him i honestly i
could not resist
it was peer pressure it was peer
pressure they peer pressured me into
ruthlessly shooting him to death oh my
god
that that poor man is just trying to own
this hotel
i like this i think this is a nice
design i really do
good we could own this design it took me
it took me like an hour to come up with
it
while chat was yelling at me
they were yelling at me ugly and i'm
like please oh rambo there's a creeper
and you hopped in front of me
are you okay oh yeah i'm okay i really
like wearing dreams armor i'm literally
wearing all of dream's armor and
belongings
these are the very same items that he
used to nearly murder me
it's quite nice hey i think it's time
for me to play chess
oh okay is don't you have an exam now
uh not yet can you cheer me on from the
sidelines while we wait for the chat
sure
i really would appreciate it if you guys
would stick in the stream i know chess
isn't everyone's strong suit
if you would support me we'll be doing
predictions which are going to be fun
yeah okay game in four minutes yep ah
i'd appreciate it if you stuck around
for the for the ride
i swear i'll make it interesting last
time we did some singing we did some
dancing when we were winning and the
time before we did some moping when we
lost
so i don't know yeah
i really don't of course streamer people
love oh topic of the hotel would
be like the runner-up to the employee
just
oh my god i'll be here wait oh my god
okay
i oh people are asking to be like runner
up for the
be employee of the month
oh it's gonna be so not lovely
it's going to be awesome i'm going to
collect a lot more resources today and
maybe see like how we're going to build
it
yeah i'm excited wait why would i search
up chess.com does
tubbo's new secret channel brackets leak
to come up
whatever whatever
my new secret channel has been leaked
how will i ever cope
how will you how will you cope with that
oh man
how will i ever cope
this is truly awful look at you doing
chess wow
look at me doing chess like a like a
like a like a twitch streamer
yeah my
my twitch streamer plays chess my stream
is five head
i guess that much and apollo fan for the
um five gifted jesus christ
yeah chat for those of you that don't
know why i'm so tired me and rambo were
talking on discord
until 10 a.m nearly 11.
and yep i want to die
was there i don't think our conversation
was that bad no i'm
tired and now i have to use now i have
to use big brain to play chess
oh shoot yeah wait yeah no wait
um i don't
um my streamer is married oh god
oh god
oh my goodness time pipers
yeah oh god
my stream would do board game it's not
just a ball game
oh my god we should do a monopoly stream
sorry that just crossed my mind
oh no okay yeah monopoly was so much fun
i played it i played it with um i played
it with um
with uh dream bad and sap nap and carl
and it was so much fun because we took
it super seriously
oh my god we like like it was doing a
monopoly stream
let's do chat we hit the sub goal today
oh i'll do a monopoly stream
subscribe for the monopoly stream and
also the irf stream
oh wait why don't i have hold up do you
not have twitch prime
no i'm setting up here i'm pretty sure
wait i'm pretty sure that
i'm pretty sure that i gave for when
jack was doing a subathon i gave my
prime to jack so i'm just
here i'm bj minton the founder of grip
six
when i was 14 my very first job was a
janitor at an elementary school
and i saved up my money and one of the
first things i bought was a wooden
chessboard
from the mall i love chess chess is
challenging chess is thinking ahead it's
planning it's problem
solving it's very similar in
manufacturing because
in manufacturing it's nothing but
problems but problems are what stimulate
your brain
problems are the things that actually
push you into creating new things new
technology better products things like
that
at grip6 we make belts wallets and socks
we guarantee them for life
and just like chest they'll be around
[Music]
forever
yesterday group 6 gave away a premium
chess set made specifically for the
tournament the winner was not
tuckery gillery so congratulations you
guys can actually
win things if you chat and if you spam
kappas that's not going to help your
chances so
make sure you're in the list as they're
giving away some belts and socks
if you want your hands on their amazing
socks belts and wallets
be sure to use code pogchamps20 at
go.chess.com
champs now let's get back to the action
we have
one game today it's going to be well
one match code miko versus tubo uh cutie
you've been saying that code miko has
been training do you want to give a
little bit more details into that if you
have any
yeah she she finally
decided i think anybody who streams on
twitch doesn't like being a loser
and was just sick of it and so then she
she spent hours like six hours the other
day just playing chess back to back to
back
she's trying really really hard i
don't i i think i mean obviously i think
tubbo is definitely still the favor here
but i don't know i just want every it's
so hard it's so hard when you have to
choose because you say the thing about
tubbo and it's grandpa i'm like i want
to
win and then i'm like oh me going to win
and i don't know so it's hard but
yeah absolutely i want a good game i
feel that is a little bit more fair
since both code miko and tubo have been
training they're both great creators
and i actually see that code miko is now
over 400 last time she's in the 300
range so we see some progress
yeah she's been grinding i think she
still doesn't know
uh like any solid openings to my
knowledge she doesn't have any of those
lines like really
memorized but it looks like she's
working on
she's doing the copy technique here the
coffee technique that sounds much better
than the actual name so let's just go
for that the petrov is now the copy
technique
and i will say this is not the best
opening for beginners to play because
it includes a lot of theory and it's
pretty tactical is this something you
tried before
um i well that's what so when i learned
black
that is what levy told me levy told me
just copy what they're doing
oh okay and so that is what i told her
actually
yeah like at the beginning when you're
on black side it's just so it's so hard
to know so that's actually some five
head advice for cramming for a chess
game it's like the spark notes for it i
appreciate that
and it's good to see tubbo vibing as
well he's always
dancing every time he's playing his
games
yeah that's what i've learned about good
streamers and why i can never be one
is that they have so much energy and i'm
like
on my 12th cup of coffee like i can't
dance still
like i don't i don't get it it's okay
you bring all of like the uh humor you
know and the wit so that's important as
well
yeah i guess maybe just bitterness i
suppose
just a sprinkle of bitterness here and
there is okay
speaking of being i don't know he's not
bitter
but he's taking a long time here he took
almost one minute
to make his fifth move bishop b5 and
this is a totally
okay move that being said code miko is
going to be able to develop pretty
quickly here
oh okay and he's just trading off all of
her pieces
uh knight takes c7 and now i guess
tubble can take the knight on d7 or he
can retreat
and okay pushes d4
instead see miko's actually and this is
like small things that probably people
don't notice but mikko's actually doing
so much better than she ever has played
because she's making conscious thoughts
like
i'm going to take that bishop with my
knight instead of my queen because i
don't want to lose my queens like
this seems like a small step in chess
but this is big for mikko cause she's
brand new
like she didn't know how the pieces
moved so this is still exciting
absolutely and last time i saw her game
she was making most moves within like
two
to ten seconds she was playing so
quickly and now she's actually slowed
down a little bit and if she can keep up
that tempo
i think that's her best chance uh to go
up against someone who's twice her elo
and for the record miko isn't feeling
well today so that's why her cam
isn't on um but she still showed up to
play which is amazing
yeah you're right i was i was gonna just
not say anything and maybe people would
think that's her camera since she's a
tuber anyway just staring intensely at
tumbo the entire time
oh man okay so tubbo is in check now and
he's going to have to defend the check
so he can either play bishop d2
or knight c3 why do you think he pushes
his pawn instead of
developing his pieces here
alex that is a question that i
definitely know um
you're the woman jim and you know what
if you stay with confidence we're gonna
run with it
he did that because he he because he
wanted to alex
and that's why you know what this is the
kind of expertise
that is going to be refreshing chat we
don't get it all the time
cutie just says it like it is so it's
perfect it's about time
it's exactly exactly um well
now tubo is developing so this is good
and
oh that is not a good move you do not
want to push your king side pawn so
she is attacking the bishop but even if
he just makes a normal move and retreats
now she's going to have a big target on
her king side
so i like king side that's what i always
say it is a naked king side and uh you
you don't want to be the naked king do
you ever remember reading that fable
no the one where the king um
was given imaginary clothes by somebody
and everybody in the town was too afraid
to tell him
so he was just walking around naked
until a kid in the village started
laughing
i thought this was a famous story
oh my god emperor's new clothes
emperor's new clothes
yeah i've never i've never
i've never cutie's like this is a weird
story
where did you have to ask my dad about
that one that's
i was a disney kid i don't know okay
they didn't make a disney movie about
the naked king i don't know why
no you're right you're right if it's not
a disney movie then it's not even a real
story
so we're not gonna count it but i'm glad
to see that toppo played bishop
e3 and he's still fist-bumping
he still has so much energy he is young
and it's good that he has that energy
now you know as you
as you reach our age you get a little
bit more
i'm being told it was a disney movie and
now i'm embarrassed
yes it's okay you can add it to your
watch list
i have a i'm i have an angry cat that i
just have no
solution for him i have to let him out
really really quick i'm so sorry
no worries no worries uh go go let the
cat out
so code miko is sitting here let's see
she's a minute lower than tubbo
she's already pushed this pawn so she's
weak in her king side
and in this situation i think what she's
going to struggle with is making a plan
so she already developed all of her
pieces
what i would try to do if i were mikko
is
somehow try to get my rooks into the
game defend the pawn on g5 because
if we kick the knight out from e4 and
play something like queen d2 it might
end up being a target
and the other question is where is she
gonna put her knight after a move like
f3 she can't go to c5 right away so she
actually doesn't have
any safe squares and that is why the
evaluation just completely shifted here
because now if tubble plays f3 her pony
is trapped
cutie do you think tubbo is gonna see f3
based on what you've seen with his chest
so far
i i think he's either gonna if he
doesn't see f3 i think he's just gonna
develop his other knight
um because when in doubt as a new chess
player it's like
okay uh i don't know what to do let me
move this piece
and you just move whatever piece you
haven't moved yet oh
and he he so he i don't think he's
noticed that the knight is trapped
because what he just did
removed the um threat on e6 so now
code miko can retreat her night there so
she actually has a decent position and
on top of that the e6 pawn
cannot be protected by another pawn so
it's going to be a pretty
big weakness for him here
okay code miko's really bold she's just
pushing all over her paw
she is going all the way down i think
she wants to trap that bishop
yeah uh i i mean i i respect i respect
the hustle she's going for here
it is going to create long-term problems
but you never know what's going to
happen this early
i i kind of like her her aggressive
style do you feel like it's going to pay
off
i think oh what did we just miss
oh he moved his bishop so yeah okay
i think i think in beginner's chess
being aggressive does pay off and maybe
i'm crazy
but listen i play like a crazy person
running around just like shooting my gun
in the air and
sometimes not life right cutie okay
right yeah
chest chest chest oh man you know i just
take what i can take and i i
go as hard and fast as i can uh cutie
you know what my first
impression of you was what it was a clip
of you before you were dating ludwig
saying how you had put bed bugs in your
ex's bed
oh my god guys
that is something that is something
yeah that was you know everything you
hear on the internet
is true by the way yeah right not not
all
it's not all content a hundred percent
um
i i i don't know i was guessing it was
for content and regardless it's more fun
if people never know
so i like them not to know yeah exactly
exactly
tumble pushes g3 so both of them are
really pushing their king side pawns
i love that they're just playing with
pawns yeah are you sure you didn't give
tubbo the copy advice as well
i think i think he's just he's doing the
i don't know what to do i'm gonna do
what she's doing
oh okay so now tubbo could bring his
queen
into the party defend the e6 pawn and
put pressure on g5 that's one idea
i'm sure he's gonna see this that night
that b night scott
he's got to bring it into play soon as a
new player that's all you do you just
scan and you're like
what haven't i touched yet somebody said
something about touching more pieces
is that like how your brain works that's
how my brain works
no every single time i'm losing a lot my
brain actually goes back to the
okay levy said to slow down
donya said this so-and-so said this
i'm like this is stupid you seem so
enthusiastic
about listening to your coaches i hate
it i hate listening my coaches but then
like i actually win when i do and then
i'm like mad
oh yeah you're like i guess they do know
better than
me no i feel the same whenever my
coaches are hanging around
and sometimes i i think i know better
and then i get really punished for it
but then i'm still stubborn i think it's
a a normal gaming thing to do
okay oh hubba was attacking
on the wrong side this is a pawn game
and i'm living for it
yeah you know cutie your advice is
becoming even more accurate now i'd love
to see him develop his night because i'm
worried he's gonna forget to do it
yeah and his knight doesn't have a ton
of options right now
code miko saw the threat she played
quickly so that is
great that she didn't just burn a lot of
time on a move that only had one option
this is gonna be really really fun if we
get down to like you know two minutes i
think it's
gonna become a really fun game do you
like the
the fast chest better than five minutes
absolutely you live for the chaos i live
for the chaos
i do also i just set my arm down and it
like shook
and it made me very sad and i just like
to people should know that i think i i'm
sorry for
for such a difficult situation it's been
hard for all of us
yeah yeah exactly
well i feel bad if it's a pawn game and
tubo is just giving up his e6 pawn like
this
um in this situation he could take the
bishop and then still go protect it but
there's only one move that will protect
his pawn and i'm not
sure he sees it it's not the end of the
world if he loses it of course because
code miko's pawn structure might get a
little bit shaky too with her pushing
these king side pawns
but if he's the one to lose the first
spawn it might get in his head a little
bit
yeah i'm curious it's interesting how
slow he's playing i can see a bishop
trade here
yeah bishop trade would be totally okay
honestly even if he develops his knight
that wouldn't be too bad but i think we
should take a listen in on his stream
because he's arrowing f4
did somebody give them a rule to move
just pawns for this game
that protects that porn oh yeah yeah
that'll protect that problem that would
also get the check
he saw it and that is okay let me just
check it's not that it's protecting the
bishop so the bishop exchanged that
could cut me but
uh yeah i'm going for it rap god tubber
i'm getting my queen up and out and then
ideally
i want to get a rook there so i have two
things protecting that
but then i would have no things
protecting that work until i move this
horse
and this rook is currently completely
unprotected
like that's a freebie
all right and code miko just moves her
rook away
by moving a rook i think she's having
trouble finding the plan here yeah
there was a kind of cool line where she
could have taken the bishop
pawn takes and then bring out her queen
to attack
both of the two pawns it was very hard
to see though
but the idea of trying to bring out your
queen that hasn't moved yet
is important at this stage in the middle
game despite us always coaching people
to not take your queen out too early
i think they're both playing very
passive and like
hoping that the other one does something
first you know like i so i'm curious to
see
how this is going to end and when you
were playing pogchamps so so temple's
almost down two minutes now would that
kind of situation stress you out or how
did you deal with it
you know i'm gonna tell you something
about uh some advice i gave to mikko
is i said a lot of these low-level games
they end on time so
just play fast is that why she's been
playing so
quickly i i it could be part of it
because i a lot of the time is
you just play fast and you win on you
win on the clock and this could be one
of those situations and if it is i'm the
best coach
in pogchamps if code miko pulls this
game off cutie
you are goaded as the coach yeah we'll
see
he finally moved his knight not towards
the center because
it would have been taken on ds7 but he
did develop his night which is a great
start
it is just a little bit awkward the
knight on the rim is dim and
it doesn't have a ton of squares to hop
into unless he saw knight c2
which would protect his bishop as well
and get his knight into the game
miko doesn't know what to do i have a
strong feeling that she
doesn't have a strong idea for an attack
right now i think she might push up that
c
pawn uh just knowing her brain a little
bit she just
when you don't know what to do when in
doubt play a pawn
interesting yeah so well
remove her queen to get that out she
moves her queen that would be
very good to see here i again
bishop takes d4 would be a great move
because the pawn takes
and then she has the f6 square for her
queen but even if she doesn't combine
the two ideas and just move her queen up
one square that would be some really
solid progress like you said
she is not going to let her clock past
his
i know that there's no way she will do
that so she's going to move pretty soon
here
i'm pretty confident another cutie pro
tip i i'm pretty confident that
i told her yep clock
it's interesting how you guys have
unique perspectives
from playing because there's a lot of
things that you know coaches who haven't
had the same experience
are not going to totally understand
oh come on mikko let's go
queen e7 yeah i mean you've been playing
this game your entire
life so you're going to have a more
refined understanding of it
and you would you would never say yo
just went on the clock
you know what i'm saying like maybe i'm
gonna be like under the table and like
just went on the clock oh no she let the
time pass
oh no oh i'm nervous for it just move
that
i don't know i don't know what she's
gonna do we'll see
uh okay well let's see what other
i mean bishop takes d4 if she is
panicking she could also just go for
even trades that seems like an
okay strategy uh
i'm nervous about how much time she's
taking now yeah and what is
what is this what is tubo doing it looks
like he's phoning a friend or something
let's listen in on
this uh talk options yeah i didn't know
oh no because that's threatening the
queen oh okay right okay
i need to focus now just have to take it
that's it yeah
[Music]
think about it see if i take that with
my
rook that means that the other piece i'd
have to take with us the bishop
and that would uh
yeah yeah i win a horse out of this i
want a horse out of this
calculator that's just a free horse they
come out underneath on this exchange
[Music]
yeah yeah i want a horse from that
that's not a good move who knew i don't
think so it might be it might be
something i'm just not even seen yet it
might have actually been a brilliant
move and i'm just a freaking idiot
oh god i'm stressing myself out
jesus listen to me i'm crazy
it's it's wild how people always
doubt themselves and think that their
opponent saw some kind of brilliant move
especially in these high pressure
tournaments yeah when niko or
yeah mikko was just going for it i think
i love that he is
he was arrowing on oh oh my god rook
takes
f8 and then if he takes with the queen
or the king
she can gobble up one of those two pawns
he can gobble up one of those two pawns
yeah
um he could probably even just take h5
straight up if he wants to
yeah that that's what i see him doing he
was arrowing on his board to bring
the rook from a1 over on f1 which
i love stacked i think that's a fun idea
and he was really excited about it so i
think that might be in the near future
too
as long as he protects his queen first
then yeah i hope to see the rook f1 but
imagine he just skips it he's like screw
it
i don't wanna yeah i just wanna he keeps
arrowing rook f1 but i
i i think he's arrowing this for the
future
okay yeah he took on h5 so he got the
free pawn i will say
that goes just in panic right now i i
wish when miko panicked she would make
quiet moves like a6 instead of moves
that are
super aggressive just because at least
then
if she is panicking she won't drop as
much material
i'm surprised she played the pawns that
she pawns
or the the plays that she played i
thought she would do something more safe
i think it's
pure panic at this point right and he
does have a check made in one threat
let's see if she's going to try to get
out of it see that
yeah she would have to take the bishop
which isn't
a unusual move to do even if she doesn't
see the threat
no yeah you're right
and and temple also arrowed queen g6
which is another checkmate so he's
seeing all of his tactics here
he's feeling pretty confident right now
nope he has made in one but it's on h8
let's take a listen on his stream see if
he's gonna see this checkmate that would
be really
yeah they had to sacrifice their castle
for an exchange purely because
um it would have been a um it would have
been checkmate otherwise
okay right so uh
that's no longer checkmate if i had to
do that purely because that's a
three square
[Music]
why was that tricky
i don't know i have no clue but just
seeing the movement of bishops
is stressful i don't know definitely
wider range so that might be partly why
okay so she moved she's playing fast now
there she is that's my girl
yes no bias by the way there is no bias
i just
i just love an underdog you're a
completely subjective commentator and
anyone who says differently
is just being i also like tubbo i just
really
would love mikko to have one win
right to have to have a win and
she hasn't had a win yet in the
tournament but that doesn't mean she
didn't improve
i think she started at a lower level
than most people so
hopefully people know that and give her
credit that she had to work
harder to get to where she is than it
seems
oh interesting okay that's a great move
she's blocking the past pawn
um what tubbo could do is bring his
horsey
into the game or i mean of course
tactically he should take on g5 but if
he's trying to go for some kind of
strategic plan it's also good to
activate the night
i think mika will just start playing
with those pawns over there moving
forward i know i've been saying that
this whole time i don't think i've
called anything correctly but
well nick miko has been pushing her
pawns the entire time so i do agree with
you on that prediction
and he hits her with the check okay
simplify if he wants you can also grab
d5
totally up to him what he goes for here
as long as he doesn't blunder he's gonna
be okay
and now he has queen d8 check as well
which is a really strong move because if
the king goes to the h file
then he could bring his rook in
okay queen d6 he moved his queen from
from threat that's good
oh finally a minute and 42 seconds oh
she's
maybe see pawn that was protecting the
wrong pawn miko true but
she does have 40 seconds and tubbo has
50 so she is at least listening to your
playfast advice
and he is playing faster
miko just play just play it's okay
that's your only chance right now is
clock
true oh no there goes the rook
the five second increment is somewhat
helpful but i feel like psychologically
once you're at 30 seconds no
you're already stressed right yeah yeah
the increment is stressful
yeah yeah yeah and you don't remember
when you started playing quickly and you
have more time you just feel like you
have five seconds the entire time
he didn't take her rook instead he
protected
the pawn right
and at least he's bringing his knight
closer into the kingside attack so
something like knight f5 oh i'm so sad
protected he's on clock right now come
on be gone
six seconds oh she saved it she saved it
she saved her clock and her rook cutie
you should be proud oh
come on mikko
oh she's she's she's hanging in there
she really
she's gotten so much better and if you
don't give her credit for that
chat you're mean and i said it all right
calling them out there not everyone is
amazing at chess not everyone has been
playing for years
oh just move just move the knight
or not oh okay so tumble can
grab it king but and
he's bringing all of his pieces into the
boat yeah he is
tumble's putting on the pressure
just run away mika run away i wonder if
she has any stalemate chances she would
have to get rid of her a7 pawn and then
sacrifice her queen somehow
oh my gosh so greedy he's grabbing
everything
just run with your king oh he's just oh
my god
if there was no pawn it would have been
a stalemate if there was no pawn on a7
oh wow yeah she actually got
really close to cell mating she should
try a5 and
and give away her pawns and see if tubo
takes them both
just like a little baby i don't think
she has any clue what to do right here
yeah yeah ah on the clock
no and she's back at 3.95 but that's
still
much higher than where she was last game
so it was a good game
she she definitely improved and you can
tell that she also learned her pacing a
little bit better it was just a really
tough
middle game position to handle right
yeah and tubbo is celebrating
tubbo is happy about this well
we'll be back with the second match
after a quick break so let's see if code
miko can come back on
that chance
okay i'm gonna take the pond because if
i go they go
yeah i don't want to trade queens
[Music]
we're on chess tv oh my gosh
highchest.com
[Laughter]
thank you so much for coming here to
this sorry i'm so stressed
everyone on chess.tv is like we're
scoping out the competition i'm like i
don't even know what i'm doing
[Music]
thank you to everyone from chess.com
who's coming to say hello
but i will never be
hey he just said pawn
oh no
how did this happen
shoot what did i do okay i'm gonna have
to go back through this
[Music]
oh thank you so much for the gifted subs
oh i'm borked i think i'm bored i think
i'm done
albert is too good
guys today i'm playing with subs if
you'd like to
yes i can spot bam like
bam and bam
is
this music also
[Music]
good morning this is
only the beginning
[Music]
welcome back to pogchamps presented by
grip6 we are about to see the second
match between
tubo and codemigo their colors have
reversed now
so we are going to be seeing code miko
with the white side of the pieces
and tubo with the black side of the
pieces cutie was telling us how much
code mikko has been grinding and she has
improved she's still the underdog
but we're going to see if she can maybe
push a little fewer pawns this game so
that she has
chances for a comeback what do you think
she's going to i know
i don't know if she has an opening
actually i i i haven't taught her the
stonewall
you didn't teach me we didn't get that
far no
in our lesson we were talking about like
the way that the night moves and stuff
like that so
i haven't taught i never taught her an
opening i think she had a lesson with
anna i don't know how far her and anna
got
um but so i'm not sure if she has an
opening memorized for white
and she can't just copy tubbo because
she moves first yeah so i don't know
what she'll do
um anna would probably know oh
so definitely not the stonewall yeah
well e4 is a good way to start too i
mean
actually in her games that i've seen so
far
her openings are actually pretty decent
once she gets out of them and i think
after her studying and it's always
random because of some kind of middle
game that's when she starts panicking
or on move to the things
that i am confident she knows is how to
mate with king and queen because we
spent a good
we spent a good while on it like oh
that's nice yeah how do you like
coaching by the way
um i only like it on people that are
worse than me um i imagine you're not
going to be out here coaching hikaru
well i scammed i scammed pokeman into a
lesson i i dm'd pokeyman and i said hey
you know i can squeeze you in for a
lesson i have to give hikaru a lesson on
sunday and then
a god i made her a lesson on monday no
she just gave her
number three oh no
this tub occurs wait is she trying to
checkmate him in four
i mean it's obviously not going to work
now but was she going for the children
yeah she was she didn't see the horse
she was just focused on what she
memorized well let's let's listen
on tumblr i'm just curious what he what
he has to say
to this don't see a tempo oh he arrowed
it
i think he saw it he's saying he's the
biggest chat am i
nice oh it's so early on and i don't
want the second game to be over
okay well no okay no that's that's rude
i don't mean i don't mean it to be like
over
but i it's it's so early
i on to i can't throw three be ruthless
oh
okay rambo and he takes it oh
i feel so mean
i know i know mikko's mad right now she
had that memorized and was just
zoned in on the on the line and didn't
actually the funny thing is
um we set up a practice match between
myth and tubbo
and tubble was nice to myth but then
mitch just took his
piece so maybe he learned his lesson
yeah i don't blame him i don't blame him
from that
oh well i don't i don't
this is tough this is tough
i i i feel i feel bad because it
felt like she had been training um
and i wish she would have had a better
game than this
not to say that yeah she's still to try
to go for that fork
on f7 with her knight right it's never
over it's never he has more of the
gambits memorized from the white side
um and beautiful castles he knows
yeah he does she did learn the bow
gambit i didn't teach her that one i
won't take credit for that but wait i
i i i know we and my sister taught code
miko but she did not teach her the
computer oh i didn't know andre i did a
lesson with her at this yeah
yeah um but yes i like giving lessons
i thought pokemane would be much worse
but she was so good that my lesson with
her was
feeble pokeman is actually really good i
think she has
chances to oh i didn't see uh yeah no
she has
chances to win the consolation bracket
okay bishop takes d4 so if you were code
miko
and you're down a little tilted how
would you approach this game if it was
your own pogchamps game
i would be tilted i would be so tilted
i think anything you do to recover oh
not that see there she's thinking wow i
just want to rook but didn't realize
that it's equal in peace
and it's not actually a good move
because bishop takes b2 would win the
rook
yeah but at least she's grabbing
something maybe if she would have
there she is yeah she might as well try
she might as well try
let's see if she sees okay now she can
attack the queen and then push the
bishop away she actually
if if she sees these two moves in a row
and
develops really quickly she has some
chances
and is that okay that's not okay
all right well is staring
into her soul right now he is
he is and and you can tell that i mean
he's playing good chess
and i i respect the fact that he took it
seriously regardless but i think he does
feel bad
after the queen blender
i will say tubbo needs to remember to
bring out the rest of his pieces
as well yeah he does leave those yeah
very like oh i've touched this i'm gonna
keep doing that
yeah yeah amazing he can play so well
with just half of the board
i know imagine if you used it right that
would be wild
that'd be wild um and here he is
he pushes d6 fantastic move he's opening
up his bishop
if he plays queen f3 and bishop h3
i'm gonna be so proud of him and goes
for the little checkmate on g2 this is a
a trick you can use whenever the light
squares are weak by the king and you
have a queen and a bishop
okay we all learned something people
that nice
nice nice um
okay cutie question for you if you were
playing hikaru
you have the black pieces hikaru has the
white pieces in 10 seconds who wins
dude carl could be with his eyes closed
and playing with his feet hikaru could
play with his feet with his eyes closed
he has 10 seconds
i panic i don't even move a piece i just
get i have
20 minutes and i still don't win there's
no chance
oh yeah that's that's fair that's fair
enough he beat me with his eyes closed
too so
we're we're all in that class he's a
robot everybody with his eyes closed you
know
i don't know what to do what's your
robot burn your robot brain the robot
robot that's true that's true
um well code miko just gave away a
couple more pieces but again
it's a tough position and she's still
putting up a fight which is good
queen h3 because imagine hubble miss
clicks or gives his queen for free you
know
that'd be very exciting no i would love
if that happened
f4 just because i want a more
interesting game
i think tubbo is so confident right now
admit it you hate tubbo oh my gosh don't
say that the minecrafters will cancel me
minecraft stands cutie cinderella hates
double extra extra get your news on
chess.com
don't do it guys stop tubbo
i'm a stan i love minecraft what tell me
some zoomer things
you're asking the wrong person
tommy in it isn't he
am i in i think i think you're safe now
cutie one time carl tweeted at me
yeah i think you're safe i think you're
safe oh
yes check okay now he can win the night
she can win that oh my gosh
hello coming back uh she has a passer
now too
she has some chances and she's good at
pushing pawns cutie
yeah i do love i do love the pawn when
in doubt push a pawn i don't know
um okay so he can
either take on f8 what else can he try
to do
what else can she try to do i say he
because there's so many male players
i've just internalized it but what can
code miko do here press.com did hit
their quota of two girls and pog champs
and yeah i will give them [__] for it
until they have three girls
because that's what we need three girls
at least three
and then you know what i'll do i'll say
at least four i like it this is your
strategy each time you add one more
until
there's 16 female participants yeah
they put me on the broadcast and then
they're like oh gosh what is she gonna
do to get us canceled today
well i think they thought that by adding
you and me to commentary then we're good
oh my gosh there are four so really ends
up i don't know how to count
oh there are four i was thinking mikko
and michelle i totally forgot about my
queen pokeman
and nico good job chats.com
yeah five next time huh
there you go there you go um all right
well well we
we got it we got it now and they
actually have a ton of female
commentators as well
so i i know they've been they've been
putting effort in on there so that's
always nice to see
it's okay me my lack of counting is why
i lost pogchamps too so
i know i mean if you would have counted
you would have beat dog dog
changes the game yeah exactly oh my gosh
this is actually a brilliant move
because she is keeping the pieces on the
board she wants to do that when she's
down material so
very impressive attempt from her here
what tubbo could go for is bishop
f3 to threaten checkmate on g2 and he
sees it and now she has to sacrifice but
i still think it was a good try by her
if i hope she sees that she can also he
can also play rook f2 but then he'll
take her bishop
so as long as as long as she protects g2
somehow
either by sacking or rook f2
and i will say if she does see the
checkmate
that is very very impressive to keep
fighting here
i mean i didn't even imagine she'd be
able to go this far after she lost her
queen so early
yeah no she's she's recovered pretty
well i don't know
i i know she knows that something is bad
here
um because sometimes i feel like you get
in this situation at the end of your
game where you're like
i know something's bad but i don't know
how to fix it and that's what just
happened
and tubbo sees the check
hubbo sees the check he goes 2-0
and truly tubbo did play these games
very well he didn't really miss a beat
he gave code miko a little bit of a
chance here but then he cleaned it up
with getting his bishop on f3 that was a
really
nice final tactic from him for sure
and you guys we will be right back with
a
post game interview with code miko and
tubbo so don't go anywhere
i think the best knife is the ruin
dagger probably just because the
animation
which one the ruin daggers from the
battle pass
see
ruined oh ruin and see what it looks
like
i don't have it hatch this from the
battle pass last season i think
that just like flips around everywhere
like when you right click it like spins
everywhere
oh that one
wait what's wrong what's up oh wait am i
on the chest stream oh wait why
okay howdy ho
yeah true we're just waiting for my
valor match to start
um yeah
uh which map we go into now what was it
i got a joke chess people it's a chess
joke
i liked our process when we got into the
agent screen it felt like everything was
clear we like knew what we were doing
what are you calling to talk about in
lobby it was a mass man
[Music]
a king and a queen living in a castle
what do you call it anybody know
it's a good one you might know it you
might know it if you're into the chess
yup yup you got it right
good job
we are joined by tubo and code miko
tubo just played two fantastic games and
code miko played despite feeling sick
today
being one of the newest to chess in the
entire tournament so even though she got
eliminated she made a ton of
progress let's maybe start double
congratulations
how do you feel these games went i i
feel
they were i was thrown off a lot by a
lot of the things that you did and uh
yeah it was still stressful nonetheless
the stress level has not changed
and code miko it looks like when you
gave your queen in the second game
you're trying to go
to checkmate tubbo in four moves is that
what you were going for
um i was trying to um honestly
i don't know what i was not thinking
oh my gosh it's so bad
i was i was i thought honestly i thought
um okay this is gonna sound really
stupid but i thought my queen was my
bishop
i love that well and i was trying to get
to the check you know the czech
thing that um that anna was
like i forgot i was like bishop to like
some some
on the board and it's like diagonal to
the king
i was yeah you were putting pressure on
the the f7
pawn the one right next to tubbo's yeah
i think that's what you were going for
yeah well i i know
cutie also gave you a ton of advice like
moving uh
very fast and trying to get under
tubble's time and it seemed like you
were doing really well with time
management in the first game cutie you
were really proud right
i was proud of you mikko you did good
thank you
you know i think i think i was also
excited to see how much extra time
you're putting in chess even though i
know it's infuriating
so seeing you just vibing the other day
for like hours playing chess
yeah that was where you got ill and um
tubbo
this the the sick twisted mind of tubbo
to take advantage of a sick girl
what do you have to say give it away oh
i feel i feel awful still it hasn't
changed
oh well you are moving forward
and you've made so much crazy progress
in chess over the last
month or so you're going to be going up
against nico
how do you feel your chances are going
to be again
i no nico no no nico
[Laughter]
um i have no idea what my chances are
gonna be i'll be honest
no worries are you gonna do anything to
prepare are you just gonna go in
jamming to the tunes and let your work
until now show itself yeah
probably just the tunes the dancing
the instruments all of that just just
the normal stuff
i know that i liked your energy it was
very impressive
thank you well tubbo congratulations
code miko thank you so much
for being a part of this tournament and
making so much progress
in chess and for battling it through
even when you were feeling sick we
really appreciate having you here
thanks for having me guys this was
really fun
all right well bye bye
no last words i'm excited to see the
next game all right
so let's talk a little bit about the
consolation bracket
we have tubo the winner of this match
going up against
nico tabo and nico are very close in
rating they're both in the 800
range so i think that is actually going
to be a very very close match and then
we have
pokemane who beat myth yesterday and
she's going to be going up against the
winner
of mr beast and michelle care who we
just saw practicing chess
while we were on break and when we look
at the
championship bracket there's a very
familiar face to cutie here
cutie do you want to talk about ludwig
versus sardoche
listen i i have my calls and i'll say
them now
pokey is winning the consolation bracket
and ludwig is winning
the winner's bracket it's time he has
worked so hard
and has missed so much
netflix time with myself by having late
night lessons with hess that if he
doesn't win
i'm gonna be livid so well if there's
any
great coach it's gonna be robert hess
and ludwig i'm sure is a fantastic
student so it's just a dream team over
there and we're also going to have
benji fishy who's been training with a
grand master as well with grand master
yoon ludwig hammer
who used to train magnus carlson and
he's going to be going
up against rayne wilson who has just
been
intimidating every single opponent so
far so
the championship bracket is going to be
super sweet gary
right benji i think benji is taking over
rayne
benji has been the scariest fortnight
kid i've ever met
and you know we've met some scary ones
and
i'm scarier than the minecraft kids you
love so much
i i i love the minecraft
look into the camera and say it with the
stream listen minecraft kids
use your twitch primes on on any channel
just use them i know there's a lot of
you
so you know uh we love minecraft kids
in yeah it's and
i don't know what to say anymore i'm so
sorry cutie yeah
because she knows how i feel about the
minecraft kids
no cutie you've been an amazing co-host
and it is so fun to have you here in
pogchamps 3
after you were there for pogchamps 2.
everybody watching i hope you had fun
and will tune in to the future games
cutie any final words you want to
add before we let them get off to the
rest of their day and raid
wgm nemo who is going to be streaming
no everyone just make sure once we get
to nemo's channel to
give her a smile and give her a follow
and maybe
and maybe a prime minister maybe a prime
all right
take care everyone goodbye
let's go
[Music]
get out take it
come out
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
better
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
so
i